well I can at least say I'm satisfied
seeing stuff like this from end Gadget
Democratic senators ask FTC to
investigate Elon Musk over his handling
of Twitter
what the lawmakers cite the botched
rollout of paid verification and the
recent departures of top privacy execs
on what grounds does that constitute an
FTC investigation he fired people
seriously and the Democrats are now this
is what corruption looks like well now
it's the Public Square it wasn't before
it's a private company they can do what
they want but now we have an issue that
the FTC needs to get involved with
that's right for years Twitter has been
wreaking havoc on our political sphere
on the public and uh nobody would do
anything about it I mean there were some
Republicans that have hearings and
they'd waste everyone's time now the
Democrats are shocked and concerned
about what's going on it's just it's all
so fake I'm done with it it's fake
you're Liars I don't care to listen to
you we are wasting our time being
bothered by even playing a game with
these people so I think the one thing
you can do right now is improve yourself
start a family have kids buy property
improve on your skills get in shape you
want to succeed and you want to win this
get fit Eat Right cut out the sugars
have a family make money that was my
favorite thing that Elon said on Twitter
like a little while ago when it came out
that he had like secret twins he was
like I have a big family and I hope you
all do too and I was like yeah okay yeah
he was saying most billionaires don't
have kids it's great but I'm saying if
you if if you think you're past path to
Victory let's say you're really good at
playing Monopoly and so you're like if I
enter this Monopoly tournament then I'll
win the grand prize only problem is you
realize that your opponent isn't playing
fairly and so you keep just playing the
game even though they're lying about
everything that's going on eventually
he's got to say maybe I should find
another way to succeed if everybody just
focuses on themselves and ignores this
obvious corruption and hypocrisy I'm not
saying don't resist it don't fight
against it I'm saying stop asking them
politely to please stop stop treating
them like they're doing this on accident
that's my Point improve yourself assume
everything they're doing is intentional
and designed to hurt you and then figure
out ways to overcome notably right now
we've got it we've got to overcome the
ballot harvesting operations they have
Scott Pressler says he's going to do it
I got faith he can let's see what we can
do to help back him and many others who
are going to start working for the 2020
on the 24 2024 election and then maybe
we can get some people in who will just
do away with this stuff
yeah people have to do something the
only one who did anything about the you
know fortification was DeSantis and well
that went how it went yeah
descendants 2024. he's the only one who
did anything everyone else complained
about it and then did nothing he made
some very interesting comments against
the world economic Forum uh today which
I thought was also kind of very
eye-opening because very few politicians
usually talk about these larger key
issues that do affect them uh but but
again with this news of this Democratic
senator asking the FDC to investigate
someone it's been seven days since FTX
went bankrupt seven days obviously
criminal fraud here obviously people
have been defrauded people have been
robbed of their money no one got
arrested Madoff got arrested in 24 hours
after his Ponzi scheme was was exposed
to everyone seven days later and then we
have the FBI warning the guy that
they're going to maybe maybe possibly be
going after him are you kidding me this
reeks of corruption and this could be
one of the reasons why Elon Musk is like
oh crap the FTC might be on my butt I
gotta do what they want me to do as the
federal government is telling big Tech
social media platforms to ban particular
voices again the US government is
violating the first amendment in more
ways than one particularly when it comes
to online speech this could be one of
the reasons why we don't have free
speech and we won't have free speech on
Twitter as announced by Elon Musk today
I think that that's probably very likely
that there's some well with this thing
about the the FTC involvement that the
federal government might have gotten in
contact with them
yeah there isn't that over the FTX
Scandal well they keep threatening him
on Twitter right and so maybe he's just
like I gotta tone things down I just
think it's crazy we can like threaten
Elon Musk FDX there's nothing but Taylor
Swift's uh General ticket sale gets
canceled and there's already a doj
investigation into Anti-Trust and
Ticketmaster they were charging like 20
000 a ticket or something oh it's crazy
it is a like wild west in the table
buying it I have six tickets I Will
Bradley announce that what what how but
you didn't so I'm a millionaire thanks
Krypton I'm just kidding
um I the whole process was insane and
you have to like register beforehand to
become a verified fan they'll decide if
you're a verified fan if you are a
verified fan you get a code it's texted
to you this sounds like a cult
are you okay I don't I don't know Hannah
Lou I'm not sure who Hannah is but like
the process was insane and the big thing
was uh I'm really sorry about this Tim I
actually bought my tickets while it was
live on pop culture on Tuesday because
of this content well yeah and the ticket
sales got delayed for so long that I
like carried my laptop up and I was like
look Brett and Mary like I'm here for
you I do this every Tuesday but I have
to get these tickets it's now or never
did the tickets come with Kool-Aid not
that I know of but maybe at the concert
she'll like inject us all I'm not sure I
just feel like as uh as a millennial
where is the concert she has a bunch she
has 52 shows how much were the tickets
uh mine were 240 dollars oh okay are you
gonna resell them no well I have I have
heard who I bought them for Ticketmaster
said that they gave out about 1.5
million of these codes put 2 million
people on the waitlist and then they
were expecting
30 percent of people who got codes to
use them and of those people like each
buy three tickets okay I don't know
where these mem these numbers hold on
hold on right so I heard it was reported
that some of the tickets are 20 grand
yeah so okay people are only selling
them you've got tickets for some people
do you think those people would be
happier to watch Taylor Swift or get 20
grand I honestly think they'd rather
watch Taylor Swift but I'll come on we
could phone a friend right now I'll let
them know the Kool-Aid is strong you
don't understand like there is such a
like I think it's twofold I think people
really like Taylor Swift she has been on
tour a while but the other thing is like
I all of my friends who want to go to
this concert were like robbed of two
years of their 20s for because of covid
like they want to go out they want to do
things because I see Taylor Swift look
man you weren't indoctrinated the way I
was a doctor we're judging you very
heavily I'm okay with that
what did you have to do to prove that
you were a Taylor Swift I have no idea
oh of 15 different people because you
re-bought them no I bought them I got a
code I don't know why I was selected
other than they wanted to like see my
heart rate go up I'm not sure uh but it
was it was this insane process
Ticketmaster crashed AOC tweeted during
this pre-sale as everyone was
complaining about it uh they're a trust
we should break Ticketmaster up because
they had oh yeah well yeah but that's
just because she couldn't get her that's
what I thought I was like this girl
wants to go to the concert I have one
more AOC if you'd like to come with me
uh no but it's it's this crazy thing
where we have this pop star returning to
tour after kovid and by Friday after
this disastrous uh sale
there's already an antitrust
investigation like oh I know it's
amazing why are they moving this quickly
Amy klobuchar's granddaughter wants to
go to Taylor Swift yeah didn't get
tickets and she's like bring the doj in
like it's the second anything in any way
negatively affects those in the
oligarchy then all of a sudden they they
put their feet to the fire and they care
how old is Taylor Swift she's 32. so
she's she's not going to be old enough
in 2024 is she
no no oh wait
oh she is gonna be old enough Taylor
Swift she's a got an idea for you her
birthday is uh uh
December 13th meaning that by the time
she would be inaugurated she would be 35
years old Taylor Swift is going to run
for the Democratic ticket that's it
that's what they're doing that's why AOC
is all over it yeah I think that makes
sense I mean I think she is that
influential among at least young voters
no way maybe I'm wrong what yeah maybe
I'm wrong maybe she's gonna be 34.
she'll be 34 I think
wait wait she's about to turn 33.
so that means she'll be 34 in in 2023
yeah she'll be 35 at the end of 20 uh 20
24. so that means she can run because by
the time she's going to be sworn in she
will be old enough to be uh president 35
right I would do anything to see a trump
Taylor Swift debate oh man I will sell
tickets to that Ticketmaster can crash
okay I'd buy those ones though like a
trump Kanye ticket versus like a swift
Obama Swift AOC Trump Kanye Swift Ocasio
we're going a little bit dangerously
into idiocracy here though yeah but at
this point I'm like you know I feel like
we're down we're going on a water slide
and like the only way to get through it
is just just to roll through it you know
what I mean yeah I mean Taylor Swift
presidency I just can't imagine IQs are
dropping so anything's anything's
possible the thing is she's a figurehead
she is the pop the pop star of an entire
generation and to so many people who
were raised especially in the social
media era she has more influence than
any politician I mean AOC has whatever
amount of followers online she has also
kind of translated herself into an
internet presence but really there are
certain people who who capture attention
and whether you like it or not Taylor
Swift is one of them and I respect that
she's not everyone's thing I myself
don't like a lot of her music but I feel
compelled like I have to go to this
concert think about like just you know
from for a moment bear with me how cool
would it be if like Taylor Swift runs
and then she becomes like the most
brutal dictator ever it's just like
extraditional extrajudicial
assassinations are through the roof
tenfold what they were under Obama and
then it's like you have like a
documentary 50 50 years from now
president Swift was the most aggressive
authoritarian leader Any Nation had ever
seen this way yeah she's like throw the
bombs
running under the campaign slogan Shake
It Off
the IQ deficit thing is really
fascinating which um because children
that were born under the during the
pandemic during the lockdowns which
again this being the first time people
can get out one study found that they
have a 30-point IQ deficit using 30
points yes
um early for for infant IQ tests which
those are not super valid but if that
maintains in in the early studies of 30
point IQ deficit that would mean that
the average person born in that
three-year period would have an average
IQ of 70 and remember average means the
middle
meaning the other half is lower than
that
horrifying it's like that George Carlin
joke he was like think about how stupid
the average person is now realize half
of them are stupider than that yeah wow
well uh I feel bad for these kids but I
mostly feel bad for myself because by
the time I'm you know in my 50s and
desperately trying to vote to save this
country or Planet you're gonna have a
lot a lot of really dumb people voting
they're gonna be like masks are good I
used to wear masks all the time
I vote for masks and it's like a mess I
think it's mandatory masking when you're
going to the bathroom they're gonna be
like I don't feel comfortable without my
mask
yeah but it's going to be like they're
not gonna say that because their IQs are
very low they're going to be walking
into a room and someone's gonna be like
you gotta take the mask off and they go
I need the mask and they go sir take the
mask off relief and then go
and then they're like okay okay okay
okay you can wear the mask jeez as
they're sucking down on their watermelon
Peach Vapes
I could just see it now watermelon Peach
is that like the flavor that you I just
made something up and as I was talking
sounds pretty it's his personal favorite
toast flavor or something I used to
avocado that was flavored babe sounds
horrific and Taylor Swift is giving them
out of her campaign really yeah yeah
there you go thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time